[Music]  Cara before we show a clip of of  enchantress you got very specific  instructions from the director of how to  get into character what were those  instructions there was a few there was a  couple serious ones which I thought were  very fair and different things to kind  of research one of them is it's like if  you ever find yourself in a forest  hopefully it will be hopefully will be a  full moon and get naked and just be out  there for as long as possible okay cool  so if I find myself in a forest and it's  full moon I'll do that David funnily  enough I found myself in a naked I did  luckily there was no one there so no one  you thought no one was there I'm a  world-class pervert with Google Maps  it was a lot of other people that doing  the same thing as I was I was like did I  even get the part that's everyone trying  to do it we have a clip now enchantress  let's take a look  [Music]  meet the enchantress  [Applause]  you